[Music]  Maes just-in-time detective would you  like to go out with me this evening  after I saw your face I felt lost I just  want to get back to work the detective  is clearly in denial help me take it  slowly  how is Lucifer I'm sure he is just fine  [Music]  [Music]  long time no see  [Music]  who are you I'm Eve as an Adam me  [Music]  whispers bringing his girlfriend encases  now huh she's actually really sweet I  don't think that you understand the  dangers of having it here when the devil  fancies for this love thee for shall be  released Eve is amazing she she hates  that I'm the devil I'm guessing this  isn't gonna end well could you accept I  truly am  I don't know you don't have to change  you're already perfect  [Applause]  this is not pretty water and the temple  this is going to be so much fun  [Music]  [Music]